day two of our hawaii adventures and i'm
so stoked because hello hello
do you know what it's called
sharks
cold shark slang shirts land
so what's super dope about sharks cove
it's like this rocky area almost like
tide pools so the water is only like
about um like maybe a foot or two uh
deep but there's a ton of wildlife so
it's perfect for beginner swimmers or
guys like him who are kind of still
scared of the water but they want to see
all kinds of wildlife sharks sharks cove
is the place to go
okay so i apparently cut that last one
too short and tyka's mad at me
because he wanted a vlog right monkey
yeah okay
sorry about that now on to tyka's
segment go taika
away
i'm away like a big one like
where do you see waveland where'd you go
to see waveland
i never went there before i only watched
those people okay can i can i end this
clip
can i cut it no hey but today we're
going to head
to oswald beach
cool yeah it was looking about a
seashell
oh tell them about the yummy thing we're
gonna eat later too
say we're going to ted's bakery we're
going to test bakery and they're known
for their chocolate jalapeno pies
[Laughter]
and the little
beach like
what's going on
i saw a cool fish in there
and then
and
can i cut it now
good job can i cut it now yeah okay
thank you
so we've been on the road now for 30
minutes or so
taika is
knocked out but this
is a hawaii
it's raining a bit but that's just
expected
of island weather it like as quickly as
it comes it goes like it just passes by
and it's like like showers all the time
um and that's hawaii to me too where
it's just like the whole horizon that's
just the ocean
no tourists aka people like us
yeah
i think anywhere there's tourists go
like they just don't know how to respect
the space
so we always like to stay away from it
so like we're from california we always
stay away we're from vegas fine we're
from california we stay away from um
hollywood
now we live in vegas we're not from
vegas but we live in vegas and when
californians come i say go back to your
state and then we stay away from the
strip at all costs because it's just the
trashiest dumpiest people ever
tourists
us yes we're pretty bad
um
i do try to leave it cleaner than i
found 100 same everything i've been
talking about
i picked up like i don't know how many
masks from the floor
because we're staying in waikiki
and like there's just random [ __ ]
masks on the floor and i'm like yo what
the [ __ ] like can you please just pick
up after yourself yeah l.a leave it on
the ground it's dirty already you won't
even meet it it won't make a difference
it's a beautiful place like this come on
man
yeah and yeah you could throw your trash
anywhere in california and it'll like
it won't make it actually just kidding
i love california kelly till the day i
die just not right now
just not right now oh i'm a hawaiian now
you wish
look at that
gorgeous landscape
this is so
soothing
relaxing
quiet
ignore the power lines but look at all
the other nature
so we've made it to sharks cove there's
a lot of features here
check that out those are the tide pools
that tech was uh papa was talking about
bringing tiger to
the scent is a little bit coarser
it is a lot rockier as you can see
however this is gonna be a lot of fun as
a little intro for taika right now we're
currently setting up shop
we put taika or i put some uh some sun
spray on his body
we got him some little
water shoes at food land which is a
local um
grocery store here that has like
literally everything
is setting up this little half tent here
it looks like this
so we're not just sitting
and baking oh cool
and a little pool oh very cool thank you
for the
for the input dude
all right just got back from snorkeling
and this guy is a man on a mission what
did you see you saw a big
dead black crap
how do you know it's dead
i like that you had your own adventures
over here
where
oh wow you're not lying
whoa that's a big oh you're not scared
to touch it
whoa
can i see
that is a crab wait is that gonna crap
yeah or is that tar oh no it's a crab
shell oh yeah
oh wow dump in the water why leave it
out here no
but he's already dead he can't come back
to life
okay
yeah you found another crab that's crazy
i see it
there's another one right there too wow
that's awesome mister how'd you see it
you got a eyeball huh
oh they went away oh it's right there
i saw a minion what i thought
two minion ones and one time i got a one
look
oh there's two more crabs that's so cool
let's do crabs hey are they wrestling
yeah i think they're doing jiu jitsu
monkey
hey good job duty
okay go to the rocks
i see something really cool
down here
you see that whoa
that's a little tunnel in there
that's pretty cool you can go inside no
i think you just did stick your head in
there yeah you could just stick your
head in and see what kind of stuff's in
there
cannot do that you cannot catch that
yeah mommy probably cannot throw that to
mom that's dangerous it's not dangerous
mama's really good mom's gonna catch his
blood bugs i must play sports
momma never plays on a sport
and they'll fit i'll swimmy okay ready
too
[Music]
trying to get lower
that's the only way you could see the
water is really buoyant i'm actually
floating yeah should i sink to the
bottom
be careful there are pumpkin right there
there's a what a pokey thing oh okay
what's so funny is this guy is a pro in
the pool
and the minute we're out on an open wall
i think it's so scary not even open
water that's true it's completely right
look at this quivering lips
monkey look look stand up look look at
papa look at papa look it's only down to
here
your whole body could be out of it your
head could be out of the water monkey
[Applause]
[Music]
monkey you're gonna watch this video and
then go oh my goodness this water is so
shallow look you can see exactly my
position
look monkey look at me see my hand
look at the quivering lips
look like you see my hand monkey this is
how shallow it is you see my hand look
at this look at this look at you see my
head
look at this
look there's sand i could touch the sand
that's how shallow this water is monkey
and this is the beautiful view
wow
black lava
you want to jump in there monkeys get
the black crab
what if papa jumps in monkey
what a papa jumps in
what if i jump in mama
alright so that was tyka's first
snorkeling trip
i think he still has some getting used
to he still is only four i think i'm
always just so impressed by his
performance in a pool
that when i take him to like open water
i feel like he'd be just as comfortable
but it is way different right like
there's rocks there's big waves there's
like big scary stuff
so we got him settled he's playing with
all the sand toys and built sand castles
and i'm on this other side now i'm gonna
try to see if there's some super cool
fish i have to take a look at
[Music]
so
that was definitely a successful snorkel
trip
because i saw a turtle
and that's like the holy grail of sea
animals when you're snorkeling in hawaii
you know and not only a turtle but i got
like literally inches away from it then
i saw a saltwater gar
found some really cool water tunnels
it was awesome like cool terrain
and it's all a bunch of other colorful
fish and i bend it all out in like 30
minutes i told ma bear like um just
because i don't want her to be worried
i'm like if i don't come back in 30
minutes then be worried so i'm right on
time see check it out
now we're at the world famous ted's
bakery in north shore which is super
cool because it's only five minutes away
from sharks cove waimea beach sunset
beach which are all super fun places to
swim we just swam at shark's cove and
here it is
ted's bakery home of the original
chocolate palkia pie
[Music]
hey who are you calling duty
anyone picking up on the other side
hello
do they hear you
they don't hear you
are you gonna put a quarter
in please
yeah
does it work
it's not working mama
what you know what's ironic this guy
will never know what this is
i really know what it
is here's the inside of the spot looks
super cozy
you got all the pie flavors there
then you go to the front and you order
you got all kinds of authentic
hawaiian food and then they got
baked goods over there
and over here is all the delicious pies
you can order a big one to go too
would you order bikini i love you too oh
you i love it too
so we play this game where tycho and i
try to beat each other to say i love you
first so then i started saying i love
you to him and then right now he was
like mom i love you
it's a cool game only two people could
play it right dude okay only two people
i want to see what you got
oh i love their portions
they're just communicating me
are you kidding me oh but this concert
you can eat the hair
this looks delicious no no that one
that's not katsu sauce oh what's that
kind of sauce i don't know
what's this one is it that's not that's
katsu sauce and what's that one i don't
know here
do you know anything
oh this might be like a little spicy
watch your hands nope
okay and then i got
garlic shrimp
i know this is blasphemous especially i
saw what you did these people take the
price
hippo
but i'm so spoiled by shrimp daddy that
i just don't want to eat any other type
of like
giovanni style shrimp
but this brought her
that looks oh good oh
suck on it
[Music]
and of course i got the halfway pies
chocolate
oh baby i'm so excited for this pumpkin
pumpkin jalapeno forgot that this thing
even existed
i know oh look at that creaminess
does it smell good
oh yeah it's like that
it's like
coconutty
pumpkin spicy
but like light and it's fluffy it looks
so fluffy
yeah
you know what you look like
you know that dude in the matrix when he
eats a steak
and he gets reminded what a steak tastes
like one more time
that's what you look like
like you've been unplugged from the
matrix and you're like oh put me back in
the [ __ ] matrix
put me in the mirror
it tastes like this wait wait i'm going
to try this one which one is that one
strawberry
oh damn look at how fluffy that one
looks
like play a player
[Applause]
it's missing the strawberry and the
guava
that's why you want to sit on that side
it keeps dripping i like it
it's really good
the moment
look at that mouth so i had to tap
strawberry guava
this is what they're known for the
chocolate alpia we'll put them on the
map
should i taste this first or the pumpkin
one you have
uh pumpkin because i think the pumpkin's
lighter in flavor okay
i hate i hate witnessing this
oh man
every time i eat it i forgot i had it
we don't come here that often so my
mouth is tainted with like [ __ ]
pumpkin pies i know sounds weird now
this is what they're known for
you know it's funny too as i get older i
don't like chocolate as much
your eyes just rolled back behind your
head what do you mean i don't like
chocolate that much
huh
i think yeah i think you're [ __ ]
needy to change your shorts
[Music]
look
[Music]
[Music]
i mean that's not in your nose is kind
of messing it all up for me
michael's on the phone who's he talking
to him
[Music]
oh okay
[Music]
okay
got back to the hotel
and straight into the pool
show me show me
what
you remember how to do all that now
that's awesome
do it again
that's awesome judy show me again
do it again yeah
that's awesome
show me that jumper showing me okay
all of a sudden all these water skills
coming right back
so happy mister
yeah cool
whoa
that's awesome oh my god did you wear
the camera sorry it's okay
go jump that
so yeah the pool at this hotel is super
nice
that's the beach
right there see all this beautiful green
the city
for the clouds
and then
put the pools right here
and the pool overlooks the rest of the
city
which is crazy nice
just showered up and now we're actually
gonna explore we're just gonna go
downstairs and walk around
and look for dinner rather than looking
for something on yelp because sometimes
you'll find just a cool hidden gem just
like at the corner or something not
hidden gym as i'm working out by hitting
jen
why are you looking at me like that
i have a headache i'm sorry mama
they made you drink more water
oh yeah you've been in the sun all day
huh
yeah
but i'm very comfortable
you look super hairy
so comfortable
oh is this guy's energy still we
literally did the world today you know
that
we did the world and this guy's still
nuts look at this pool
[Music]
there you go again oh you're just gonna
come beat me up we were at the pool
before you got there for an hour
[Music]
and we were like swimming yeah for
another hour
come here so this is cuny just walking
around
exploring the streets and i'm trying to
figure out
so papa and i make the stupidest bets
all the time and right now i need to
prove him wrong that dylan drove a
specific year of porsche that's what i'm
trying to figure out
dealing from 90210 they're like which
dylan are you talking about so you're
also you have to be a boomer to watch
that show
yes
oh my god i thought you're gonna run
across come here dude
i didn't even get to finish what time i
mean the rest of it hey get on this side
you're on the sidewalk are you kidding
me jesus christ this guy hold my hand
okay the one that you showed me was like
a 1990 or early 2000s
and i was like no he drove the classic
one and it's in your face in yo first he
drove a 1964.
porsche
356.
well i don't know where is it oh you
show me a bunch of text perfect this one
see oh yeah
i could have sworn he drove nope this
one
are you really he really wants you to
vlog him
okay what do you want you told me you
want me to vlog you what is it
you're stretching
this statue oh your statue
statue in the middle of hawaii hey if we
had to deal with this you got to deal
with this too
hey why are you always beating me up but
look at how beautiful hawaii is though
beautiful body you promise look at that
the clouds
look at the cloud oh there you go now
that's the adjustment that's what i see
so our hotel is actually pretty close to
the royal hawaiian which is really cool
because there's a ton of shops here and
we were just there yesterday with uh
junebe in that corner you might be able
to see that yellow wall right there
and today we're gonna
explore the japanese
food hall
dude why
okay
hey guess what and he beats me up again
again and again i like him for that what
about that floor right there
all right so i was just on the street
over here
and i saw a sign
right here that said there's restaurants
down this alleyway
and i was like what really so me and my
bear walk down here and it's really cool
like just in the middle of this cut
there's like a little food port
look at that
there's all this food in here
and they have ramen for one of them
and then you can go this way
there's ma bran taika down there
and there's also leo's tavern
indian food
it's really interesting this is cool at
this little food court people are eating
and after you come out of here
we're back in this alleyway
back on the street
over here
i love seeing them walk together
so cuny
all right so we reached this little
intersection which is really cool
buildings and trees all around which is
a lot of hawaii looks like this with a
lot of beautiful palm trees
cars driving around but the thing that
caught our attention is this kalo
hawaiian up
the sign was blown out but it says kalo
hawaiian food
and we're like that's pretty fitting
and this is the place
that i saw across the street carlo
hawaiian food
i know and now i'm going oh man what a
gamble i hope that's it
and then there's like a line over there
oh it's a pizza
so interesting huh
i don't come to hawaii for pizza well
what do you see what do you see dude
another bicycle this guy's been wanting
us to take pictures of him on bicycles
it's so cute all right i'll take a
picture here i'll take another one
okay here dude
are you gonna do it like that ready big
smile there you go
and what's funny
is look he said hey
hey
how's it going
so look this is the other picture i took
it's the one i
all right let's get some food let's go
lots of cool stuff on the menu
i got laulau which is the pork shoulder
wrapped in a banana leaf that's pretty
hawaiian chicken long rice i love
chicken long rice
and they got a big hawaiian platter we
can sample everything
and then they got
miso sea bass with lobster all kinds of
cool stuff oxtail is also
hawaiian favorite
all right so this is taro bread with
lilikoi butter
that already sounds like an amazing
combination oh my god
okay well it's just creamy
uh it's very soft because i don't like
when they give you
warm brown yeah and then
the butter is
how did you do that but this one's soft
give me one too then do the bottom one
it's good it's a good combo
it's taro bread yummy huh yeah
i like saying a little mouth too
so mama got the tiger prawns curry
i got the chicken long rice
and then some kahlua pork
we're all going to share this
try some of that
those prawns look big
look at that
oh that's smart
it's
good oh god it's spicy i think you can't
have this at all
it's spicy like thai level
not thai level but it's hard it's up
there
it looks really good though
so i guess taco just had these guys with
me
excuse me
made it back to the hotel room and
mama got some snacks
watch your voice look at that taika is
finishing the yummy pie which one did
you get the chocolate one
how peanut pie you like it
it's really good huh you'd be cute how
many thumbs how many thumbs
double double
let me see
hey
he likes it
that's cuny yeah we're gonna rest up now
have some family time we're watching the
other guys a movie earlier hopefully
it's still on because tycho was glued to
it
watch that i know how long that movie is
what we've been gone for like three
hours no but you know sometimes at the
cable television
hopefully it's still on yeah hopefully
it's still on we'll watch some of that
and then go to sleep
and we'll see you guys tomorrow